wo ich euch genug
neue schulstunde fängt an sozialkunde
bei vertretungslehrer werke hallo klasse
so geht disziplin freunde also mal bei
allem verständnis für die ampel in ihrem
multi krisenmodus aber es kann doch
nicht sein herrschaften das hier alles
liegen bleibt außer ukraine und energie
kurz zur erinnerung die ampel hat die
zwanziger jahre
das werden die jetzt gerade im
koalitionsvertrag zum jahrzehnt der
bildungschancen ausgerufen und wie läuft
das jahrzehnt so bis jetzt
dieses schuljahr ist das schlimmste seit
50 jahren beklagt der deutsche
lehrerverband schätzungsweise sind
bundesweit 30 bis 40 tausend stellen
unbesetzt das völliger quatsch das
schlimmste schuljahr war 1976 als meine
eltern mich gezwungen haben an den
bundesjugendspielen teilzunehmen aber
das ist ein anderes thema es war eine
einzige demütigung wir wir erleben
gerade einen historischen lehrermangel
meine damen und herren das ist eine
vollkatastrophe dabei sind die gehirne
unserer kinder noch der einzige
nachwachsende rohstoffe genau diese
kinder sollen doch später für uns ganz
neue energieformen erfinden und wir
idioten unterrichten die nur noch mit
quereinsteigern
in dieser klasse habe ich ein halbes
jahr englisch unterricht gegeben obwohl
ich gar kein englisch kann
ja gut wenn beide in baden württemberg
gibt es auch lehrer die
deutschunterricht obwohl sie kein
deutsch sprechen
inzwischen kämpfen die schulen in
deutschland um die allerletzten
quereinsteiger von echten lehrern wird
nur noch geträumt wobei sicher meine in
der unterstufe da kannst du zur not auch
mal gut trainierten schäfer und nehmen
als beispiel
von diesen komischen dinge die immer
beim gebrauchtwagenhändler rumstehen
ja
und es wird ja immer schlimmer es wird
ja noch schlimmer die kultusminister
erwarten für 2025 eine lücke von
26.000 lehrern die sich bis 2030 noch
auf 33.000 vergrößern soll das institut
für deutsche wirtschaft rechnet sogar
mit
68.000 lehrer lehrstellen 2030 ja das
werden harte zeiten übrigens auch für
eltern denn der unterrichtsausfall sorgt
ja nicht nur für die kinder sondern auch
für logistische probleme um 9 uhr 20 ist
der schultag in schleiz vorbei dann
stauen sich die elterntaxis vor der
schule denn der nächste schulbus fährt
erst um halb zwei
die kinder können doch auch mal nach
hause trampen wir doch auch gemacht
früher oder sie können laufen denn
landkreise in deutschland entscheiden
selber wie lange ein schulweg maximal
sein darf und da geld 90 minuten
schulweg oft als zumutbar ja und
vielleicht sollte man den weg zur schule
einfach schon zum lernen nutzen sonst
ist es ja tote zeit mehr los geht's mit
chemie in der u bahn
in der u-bahn lernt das schulkind
spielerisch wie sich die moleküle von
urin und schweiß chemisch verbinden dann
geschichtsunterricht beim ewigen warten
auf den anschlussbus
erzählt irgendeine opa dass nicht alles
schlecht war unter hitler und zum
schluss matte beim drogendealer hinterm
bahnhof
wenn ich zwei gramm koks kaufe das mit
10% backpulver gestreckt ist reicht das
dann bis zur großen pause
und damit wir uns hier ganz re die
verstehen die meisten dieser missstände
liegen natürlich weiter in der
verantwortung der länder
allerdings laufen zum jahresende die
bundessubvention fürs schulessen aus das
ist ein super ampelsignal in zeiten der
inflation nicht ob ja ja und das problem
lehrermangel lässt sich kurz und
mittelfristig leider gar nicht mehr
lösen weil man so blöd war über jahre
lehramts studienplätze abzubauen wir
haben die abgebaut in manchen
bundesländern gibt es außerdem einen nc
ausgerechnet für angehende
grundschullehrer und dann wundern sich
alle dass man keine mehr finden es gibt
schlicht keine bewerber für die stimmen
und die sind alle ausgeschrieben auf der
homepage des ministeriums
die magic wurde ist gering zu sagen 00
verstehen 0 ist das wenig
schützen so gerne sagen aber bei mir ist
mathe immer ausgefallen
mehr wertschätzung für lehrer könnte
extrem helfen in vielen bundesländern
mussten sich auch diesen sommer wieder
nicht verbeamtete lehrer arbeitslos
melden über die ferien insgesamt 5700
davon allein 1600 in baden württemberg
idiotische schikane was soll das wenn es
je einen fall von am falschen ende
sparen gab dann ja wohl den stadt diese
menschen in der sänfte zur arbeit zu
tragen schicken wir sie ins jobcenter
sonst noch innovative ideen wir müssen
wege finden dass schülerinnen und
schüler sich auch zeitweise selbst
beschäftigen vor allem die älteren
schülerinnen und schüler und dann auch
nichts von einer lehrkraft beaufsichtigt
werden müssen ja genau
oder wir schaffen die schulpflicht ganz
ab dass wir auch eine möglichkeit das
einzige was den bundesländern aktuell
dazu einfällt ist sich gegenseitig
lehrer abzuwerben
wovon es aber insgesamt nicht mehr
werden das hat sogar ich verstand mit
meinem nrw
vorschlag wohl auch gerade über die
allgemeine dienstpflicht gestritten wird
könnte man die mich ausweiten
deutschland hat zu viele schüler und
viel zu wenig lehrer darauf kann es nur
eine antwort geben die allgemeine
wehrpflicht volljährige im wehrfähigen
alter werden ab sofort zum zwang
schuldienst eingezogen diese mutter
hatte große pläne für ihren sohn das
kann sie jetzt vergessen im sogenannten
kreiswehrersatzamt muss sich der
angehende zwangs lehrer einer reihe
aufwändige prüfungen stellen kann der
gemusterte den sound eines deutschen
pausenlos nervlich aushalten bezwingt er
den gefürchteten overheadprojektor
tricks verrät wer es jetzt noch schafft
ein stück kreide vom boden aufzuheben
und dabei zu husten erhält umgehend den
dienstrang studienrat und die uniform
wir nun stolz bis zu seiner burnout
frührente mit 48 tragen wird jeanshemd
mit schweißflecken darüber natürlich
kosako kurz gesagt sein leben ist vorbei
außerdem hat jede deutsche schule ab
sofort ihr lehrpersonal selbst zu
rekrutieren mit welchen mitteln auch
immer die allgemeine wehrpflicht wir
geben euch an
[Applaus]
wir werden jetzt andere saiten
aufgezogen
meine damen und herren hinter uns liegt
die erste woche unseres lebens mit einem
britischen könig fühlt sich immer noch
seltsam an ist noch sehr ungewohnt
charts der dritte tastet sich vorsichtig
ins neue amt und was ich ja wirklich
toll finde an dem man hier er hat nie
den kontakt zu den einfachen menschen
also zum normalen alltag verloren wie
sein früherer butler zu berichten weiß
über die zahnpasta jeden morgen auf die
zahnbürste gedrückt sein bart wird mit
einer ganz bestimmten temperatur und
einer exakten wasserhöhe eingelassen und
seine schlafanzüge jeden morgen gebügelt
auch seine schnürsenkel müssen jeden
morgen gebügelt und geglättet werden ja
was gar nicht worüber sie lachen haben
sie keinen der in die schnürsenkel
bügelt
hör gar nicht hin james einfach weiter
glätten
und bitte an die bügelfalten denke ich
kontrolliere das nachher ja
den habe ich mir vom rbb
geliebtes der dritte pflicht hat seinen
eigenen stil und da gibt es tatsächlich
interessante parallelen zum ebenfalls
bereits gut abgehangenen cdu regenten
friedrich merz behauptet jedenfalls
irgendwer mit medien
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
auch in diesen tagen von großer trauer
wehmut und umbrüchen muss kritischer
journalismus unerschrocken nachfragen
immer brauchen wir das noch diese
überkommene ewiggestrige teure womöglich
längst branche institutionen die
christlich demokratische union
genau und natürlich das britische
königshaus jahrzehnte wurden beide union
und monarchie von eisernen regentinnen
verwaltet hier zum beispiel around
angela merkel guck mal ist da hinten ist
dass schimmel friedrich merz und
schlagfertig die kreise queen ja ich
habe auch so ein lappen zu hause was
hätte ohne das eherne matriarchat aus
diesen beiden jungen männern werden
können stattdessen entwickelte sich
überkingen formel 1 oder es kommt zu
einem schuldigen kostüm ständer und der
junge christdemokrat zu sprechen wir es
offen aus friedrich merz die beiden
langzeitarbeitslosen stürzten sich in
die trunksucht und in schlechte
gesellschaft bleibt gesund
forscht
ihre politische und gesellschaftliche
agenda verhakte sich irgendwo in den
70ern und blieb für immer da märz führt
jetzt zähneknirschend in der cdu die
frauenquote ein wären charles
pragmatisch sagt der herr frauenquote
bin ich das selber und sich auch
politisch relevante themen konzentriert
wie den kampf gegen graue eichhörnchen
charles ist halt einen tick moderner und
ernährt sich auch gern vegetarisch bei
seinem ableben sollen übrigens 96 salat
schüsse abgefeuert werden märz dagegen
hadert noch mit der gender sprache und
verhaspelt jede pointe aber wir haben
hier nicht wunderland in deutschland wir
sind nicht bullerbü finanziell zählen
beide spätzünder so zur abgehobenen
mittelschicht charles musste bisher mit
23 millionen pfund pro jahr auskommen
und märz muss immer aufpassen dass er
nicht darüber lacht mit zarten 73 jahren
besteigt charles endlich den thron dazu
seine gemahlin besteigen ist halt
einfach sein ding im unterschied zu king
charles muss der arme märz übrigens
immer noch alles selber machen keiner
hilft in die büroklammer zu lösen die
plauze weg zu knüpfen und soundcheck
[Musik]
jetzt ist der tontechniker taub wie
souverän hingegen der souverän der
kleine könig kalle wirsch hadert mit dem
schreibgerät droht dem lack ein tags
drauf legt auch noch der königliche
füller kein problem soll sich doch die
gattin mit tinte beschlossen wer hat
also großbritannien einer glorreichen
zukunft aus monty python loriot und
immerwährender sitcom entgegensieht hat
der könig bereits weitere pläne meine
damen und herren es
ist mir eine große ehre
eingeladen worden zu sein
ok also deutsch hatte war howard
carpendale gelernt sind übrigens auch
gegen geringen aufpreis klassiker wie
deine spuren im sand aber er macht schon
gute figuren deutschen bundestag charlie
ist zwar genauso ein verwöhnt das
riesenbaby wie fritz aber wenigstens
redet er nicht ständig über das gender
vorschlag karls wird nächster cdu-chefin
nächster kanzler was sagt man dazu
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]